bonsoir à tout ce nous sommes le
mercredi 8 juin vous regardez le 7 8 le
journal merci de nous retrouver comme
chaque jour nous allons revenir sur les
informations qui font l'actualité locale
avec nous inviter mais également avec
les journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite les titres de cette édition
à une semaine de la journée mondiale du
don du sang le 14 juin établissement
français du sang a lancé jeudi dernier
un appel urgent à la mobilisation des
donneurs pour nous en parler ce soir en
plateau avec nous le docteur jamal
benomar directeur de la collecte en
ile-de-france et à plaisir les travaux
avant sur le chantier de la rd 30 malgré
les dernières intempéries le projet
arrive dans une seconde phase plus
impactante pour ses usagers si le
rond-point des gâtines va prochainement
être mise en service
celui du pressoir va être fermé le point
sur ce projet phare du département dans
cette édition
mais vous n'avez pas eu la chance
d'avoir les précieux sésame pour
assister aux matches de l'euro 2016 mais
vous voulez quand même participé à
l'ambiance de ce grand événement dans
quel bar vivre les matches de l'euro à
saint quentin en yvelines les réponses
dans ce journal
et pour commencer cette information 782
communes sont reconnues en état de
catastrophe naturelle après les
inondations historiques et des derniers
jours l'arrêté de catastrophe naturelle
pour ces communes situées dans 17
départements a été prise ce mercredi en
conseil des ministres ouvrant la voie à
une indemnisation plus rapide pour les
sinistrés un premier arrêté
interministériel reconnaissant l'état de
catastrophe naturelle dans 781 de
communes situées dans 17 départements
sera publié dès demain au journal
officiel par ailleurs 215 dossier de
communes sont en attente d'être traités
l'afa l'association française de
l'assurance a évalué mardi le montant
final des dommages assurés entre 900
millions et 1,4 milliard d'euros selon
le porte parole du gouvernement stéphane
le foll
les inondations qui ont essentiellement
touché le nord-ouest de la france et le
bassin parisien ont fait cinq morts et
24 blessés
nous y reviendrons demain dans le jt
avec une édition spécialement consacrée
aux intempéries siens et c'était une
opération de grande ampleur et hier soir
vous avez peut-être croisé la police
circuliez dans les yvelines une
opération départementale simultanée de
contrôle routier sur chaque
circonscription d'agglomération a été
mise en place de 18h à 20h l'objectif
lutter contre l'insécurité routière et
diminuer le nombre de tués sur les
routes
un reportage signé camille lambert non
port de la ceinture usage du téléphone
et absence de clignotants autant de
mauvaises habitudes qui peuvent coûter
la vie
mardi 7 juin une opération de contrôle
routier a été mise en place sur tout le
département
un moyen de diminuer le nombre
d'accidents sur les routes sur le même
créneau horaire dans les neuf
circonscriptions d'agglomération des
départements on mène simultanément des
contrôles routiers d'ampleur vous voyez
on a des bleus débloquer un certain
nombre d'effectifs n'a en tout j'ai à
peu près une vingtaine de policiers qui
sont mobilisés sur ce point contrôle
pendant deux heures sur les 20 points de
contrôle 468 véhicules ont été examinées
au total 86 infractions relevées une
action qui permet aussi à la police de
sensibiliser les conducteurs pour être
visible pour avoir une action de
communication parce que c'est pas
uniquement répressif c'est aussi très
préventif ce qu'on essaye de faire et le
but c'est éventuellement bas de pouvoir
toucher et
voir certains comportements routiers qui
sont mauvais pour pouvoir les corriger
par la suite ces contrôles de grande
ampleur ont lieu une à deux fois par
mois
à l'issue de cette soirée trois mesures
de gardes à vue ont été prononcées dont
une pour port d'armes illégal en mai
sept personnes sont décédées sur les
routes dans les yvelines
et c'est un projet phare du département
l'aménagement et l'élargissement de la
rd 30 à plaisir hier à l'espace coluche
la mère de plaisir josefina coleman
bergers accompagnés d'élus et de
représentants du conseil départemental a
tenu une réunion publique pour informer
les usagers de l'avançon du chantier le
chantier rangoon dans une deuxième phase
de travaux après avoir lui aussi subi
les intempéries les détails et tout de
suite
les automobilistes devront s'armer de
patience la seconde phase de travaux
commencent pour le chantier de la rd 30
une annonce faite mardi soir à plaisir
par la mairie et le conseil
départemental auprès du public partir là
deux mois de juin jusqu'à à peu près le
mois d'octobre y avoir pas mal de
transformation au niveau de la
circulation surtout au niveau du plateau
et des gâtines une phase plus impactants
pour les usagers de la rd 30
la mise en service du giratoire des
gâtines va rendre trois voies de nouveau
accessible les automobilistes pourront
donc emprunter une voirie provisoire
entre ce dernier et la rue pierre curie
ils pourront également circuler dans les
deux sens entre le rond-point et la rue
monnot mais pour avancer les travaux
l'accès du rond-point du pressoir va
être supprimé en conséquence plus
d'accès à la connexion entre la rd 58 et
la rue curie depuis l'encours
même situation pour la connexion rue
monnot et la rd58 cette seconde étape
devrait débuter rapidement malgré les
intempéries qui ont eu des conséquences
sur le chantier sa secte et je dirais
pendant quelques jours mais on peut pas
dire que véritablement c'est apporter un
grand retard par rapport aux chantiers
c'est un chantier
qui va durer pratiquement deux ans et
demi donc je dirais qu effectivement
c'était assez sévère mais mais je pense
pas que ça porte je dirais préjudice
énormément au chantier sur la durée en
tout cas l'aménagement et
l'élargissement de l'air d'être en tête
un projet majeur pour le département une
opération à 78 53 millions d'euros qu'il
a financé à 58% vous relier des bassins
de vie qui sont celui de poissy celui de
plaisir et l'encours avec la ville
nouvelle et la n12 ce sont vraiment des
axes structurants avec un niveau de
circulation qui ne fait que croître
d'année en année et au bout d'un moment
il y avait je dirais des axes de
circulation qui devenait emboliser et à
partir de là il fallait quand même
apporté une fuite et le nouveau
carrefour de la rue jules et renier
devraient également être mises en
service cet été
la fin de l'ensemble des travaux de
voirie est prévue pour l'été 2010 est l
on parlait santé à présent dans notre
entretien mardi 14 juin la semaine
prochaine c'est la journée mondiale des
donneurs de sang alors que cette journée
importante pour le ffs se prépare
l'organisation a lancé un appel
d'urgence était jeudi dernier nous
recevons en plateau docteur à jamal
benomar dont sort à vous merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
vous êtes directeur de la collecte de
lait fesses en ile-de-france alors
revenu sur cet appel d'urgence est ce
que c'est un état grave c'est un état
une situation exceptionnelle que nous
vivons alors habituellement nous
l'établissement français du sang
s'organise de façon à avoir des stocks
suffisants pour chez pour gérer les les
besoins des malades franciliens de façon
à avoir un stock aux alentours de 12 à
14 jours
depuis quelque temps avec les grèves
qu'il y a eu avec surtout des
intempéries nombre de collectes ont été
annulés notamment en île de france mais
aussi en région
donc c'était après des intempéries les
collectes ont été annulés mais nous vous
n'avez pas dû vous fournir plus pour les
gens qui ont été peut-être sinistrés qui
ont été également non non on n'a pas dû
on n'a pas fait appel à nous pour cela
n'a absolument
est-ce que vous allez baignol et
spécifiques où c'est vraiment global sur
alors on peut pas parler de pénurie
puisque le l'établissement français du
sang organise comme je voulais dire de
façon à voir des stocks suffisants pour
gérer alors par contre comme il ya des
mouvements sociaux qui lie à des
intempéries de façon importante les
donneurs les personnels ont du mal à se
déplacer et ont du mal à arriver sur
jusqu'à nos points de collecte raison
pour laquelle l'établissement français
du sang en ce début d'été si on peut
parler des buts difficulté francs un
appel en urgence aux français de façon à
ce qu'il y ait à ce que les stocks
remonte de façon conséquente nous
attendons au moins trente mille dons
supplémentaires à faire là dans les
prochains jours alors justement ces
initiations au tir et sont à la veille
de l'été parce que c'est en été que la
situation est fragile pour vous
absolument lorsque vous savez que
beaucoup de beaucoup de beaucoup de gens
peuvent partir en vacances et c'est tant
mieux
les malades nous la maladie non nos
besoins sont réguliers tout au long de
l'année puisque je vous le rappelle il
ya quand même un million de malades de
feu de malades un million de citoyens
français qui dépend de la transfusion
sanguine 500 mille d'entre eux sur une
sur des poches en phase liquide et 500
mille autres qui dépendent des
médicaments dérivés du sang partir du
classement est aussi un grand événement
qui arrive c'est l'euro 2016 on va
accueillir plus de personnes en france
s'est également allié anti pas ça
s'appelle oui s'il y est à peine mais
mais mais nos besoins sont là il faut
europe à l'euro il faut absolument que
ces stocks la remonte absolument capital
comment vous organisez dans ce genre de
situation est ce que vous multipliez
peut-être les collectes mobiles
alors il y a effectivement ont multiplié
les collectes mobiles il y as je vous
rappelle qu'il a des six fils qui sont
eux qui sont qui sont là qui sont
ouverts toute l'année
je vous rappelle que sur
le sur les yvelines par exemple la
semaine alors le 14 juin effectivement
c'est la journée mondiale des donneurs
de sang pour eux mais pour remercier ces
donneurs de sang mais aussi les
bénévoles qui s'activent autour du don
du sang
et bien je vous je vous le signale que à
l encours par exemple le mardi 14 juin
de 9 à 19 heures à l'hôtel de ville il
va y avoir une grande collecte sur
versailles du mardi 14 au vendredi 17 de
9 heures à 20 heures avec une petite
coupure d'une heure à bord d'un véhicule
proche de l'hôtel de ville et aussi le
vésinet la semaine d'après en fait il
pour donner son sang c'est extrêmement
simple il suffit d'avoir la bonne
adresse
et on peut la retrouver dans
dondusang.net alors est ce qu'il ya des
régions qui sont plus concernés en ile
de france il ya beaucoup donneurs de
sang moi alors les yvelines est un
département qui quand même est
extrêmement généreux puisque juste dans
soixante dix huit l'année passée nous
avons collecté près de 30000 personnes
qui n'est absolument pas du tout
négligeable
c'est très important et nous avons
besoin de dix mille dont jours en france
et 1700 dont 1700 en ile-de-france alors
vous le disais il ya ailleurs des
initiatives spécifiques donc pour cette
journée mondiale des donneurs du sang
donc le le 14 juin ça va s'étaler sur
toute la semaine toute la semaine il va
y avoir des initiatives pour que les
gens puissent venir donner leur sang
absolument avec un point important au
niveau 2 du cour saint-émilion à bercy
dans le à paris où il va y avoir donc
pendant trois jours le 13 le 14 et le 15
juin un événement exceptionnel puisqu'il
va y avoir de l'animation il va y avoir
une
un grand chapiteau qui va être monté de
façon à accueillir les jambes dans les
meilleures conditions
pourtant on aurait pu penser vous montre
les deux sens mais après donc les
attentats qui ont touché la france en
novembre dernier à paris il ya eu
beaucoup de doutes on va dire voilà qui
sont des personnes qui sont présentés
pour donner leur sang
ces donneurs là il redonne leur sang
vous les voulez les remobiliser
alors effectivement la mobilisation des
parisiens défense enfin des français
d'une façon générale mais des parisiens
a été absolument exceptionnelle nous
n'avons jamais observé un tel afflux de
donneurs effectivement
vous savez que nous lorsque l'on donne
son sang c'est pour sauver une vie et
comme les stocks étaient suffisants à
l'époque nous avons fait remplir des
promesses de dons et bien aujourd'hui
effectivement il y a l'événement étant
un petit peu loin
il y a une petite désaffection des au
niveau du don en france d'une façon
générale la sécu c'est les jeunes il
faut peut-être plus leur en parler les
remobiliser les nouveaux donneurs ce qui
viennent d'être majeur qui savent
maintenant donner leur sang absolument
il suffit d'être âgé de plus de 18 ans
pour venir donner son sang en faire la
preuve avec une pièce d'identité et
c'est tout ce qui est demandé
puisqu'après vous avez cet entretien
médical prénom qui va s'assurer que le
donneur peut donner du sens à mettre en
péril son état de santé son état de
santé ni celles du malade du receveur
ont fait suffisamment justement voilà de
communication à destination à des jeunes
selon vous peut être aussi à d'autres
tranches d'âge nous essayons d'organiser
des collectes à chaque fois que cela est
possible notamment dans des
établissements scolaires là où il y à
des majeurs et le secteur de
l'enseignement est quand même un secteur
qui est important puisqu'il faut
absolument donner l'habitude aux jeunes
de passer à l'acte et de le perpétuer
surtout c'est difficile surtout de
fidéliser les donneurs alors en ile de
france il ya beaucoup de mouvement vous
savez qu'il ya beaucoup d'étudiants et
une fois qu'ils ont donnée il leur
arrive au bout de trois quatre ans de
quitter la région
mais peu importe le principal c'est de
continuer at a donné quel que soit
l'endroit où on travaille où on vit en
france
alors si justement vous l'avez dit on va
le rappeler si on souhaite être nouveaux
donneurs aussi elle a fait un certain
temps qu'on n'a pas donné son som
comment on fait qu'est-ce qu'elles
soient les informations pour pouvoir
revenir va faire ce don alors il y à des
lyonnais face excessivement simple il
suffit d'avoir la bonne adresse
et on la retrouve dans don du sang
premier il ya toujours une collègue
proche de chez soi de son lieu
d'habitation de son lieu de travail
venir avec une pièce d'identité si
c'était le premier don et voilà et se
laisser guider vous avez quatre étapes
vous avez un accueil vous avez un
médecin qui va faire le point sur votre
état de santé actuel passé médical vous
contre votre comportement à risque
éventuellement et vous serez éligible à
la condition que vous ne mettiez pas en
péril votre état de santé ni celles du
malade
c'est une infirmière diplômée d'état qui
va vous prélevez avec du matériel
stérile à usage unique et enfin une
collation vous sera proposé la seule
précaution à prendre bien bois avant
bien boire après
l'eau et ses quatre fois par an qu'on
peut donner son sang si je me trompe pas
pour une femme on peut donner jusqu'à
quatre fois par an par contre les
garçons peuvent donner jusqu'à six fois
jamais à moins de deux mois d'intervalle
entre deux dons ne pas oublier d'autres
dons qui sont absolument capitaux c'est
le don de plasma et le don de plaquettes
merci beaucoup docteur alors voici vous
voulez plus de renseignements si vous
voulez vous aussi donnez votre sang et
que vous avez entendu donc l'appel de
l'es7 n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran voilà pour faire un don qui
sera forcément bien sûr plein de l'utile
au poids suite merci à bourseul et nous
restons dans le domaine de la santé mais
cette fois à plaisir une dizaine de
défaut des défibrillateurs cardiaques et
on courra d'installation sur les lieux
publics de la commune alors à cette
occasion les conseillers municipaux
reçoivent une formation pour les
utiliser en cas d'urgence l'occasion
aussi de voir ou de revoir les gestes de
premiers secours les explications de
camille lambert et patrick jacques de
dixmude conscience demande en cas de
malaise cardiaque
les défibrillateurs font partie des
trois gestes qui sauvent la commune de
plaisir a décidé d'en installer 11 dans
des lieux publics comme la mairie annexe
le palais des sports ou encore le
château c'est quelque chose qui manquait
à la ville bien évidemment oui c'est
indispensable aujourd'hui si on veut
effectivement assurer la gérer la
tranquillité une certaine tranquillité
bon les chances de survie ne sont pas
toujours 100% mais tranquillité de
l'ensemble des personnes qui pour
l'ensemble des personnes qui fréquentent
ces lieux publics plaisir a souhaité
former en premier lieu des élus sur la
base du volontariat
les employés municipaux seront eux aussi
sensibilisés depuis mai 2007 toute
personne même non médecin est autorisé à
utiliser un défibrillateur automatisé
externe et fonctionne sur le même modèle
alors la seule variante est temps que
certains
vont aussi vous proposer de lancer le
choc tout seul donc on va dire attention
analyses en cours choc recommandé
eloignez-vous 3 2 1 et il en sort tout
seul donc on a ces deux possibilités en
france à voir les défauts blatter
entièrement automatique ou semi
automatique semi automatique c'est quand
on appuie sur le bouton d'ici les mois
de septembre octobre deux véhicules de
patrouille de la police municipale
seront à leur tour équipés de
défibrillateurs la commune ya consacré
un budget de 15 mille cinq cents euros
et cette information qui vient de nous
parvenir la piscine salvador allende des
clayes-sous-bois sera fermé jusqu'au 17
juin
suite à des prélèvements régulièrement
effectués la piscine avait dû fermer ses
bassins la semaine dernière en raison de
la présence d'un agent bactériologique
elle devait initialement réouvrira ses
portes le 9 juin dernier
or dans la tente des nouveaux prével
prélèvement effectué ce lundi matin
qu'ils ne seront disponibles que le 17
juin prochain
les responsables de l'équipement ont
préféré repousser cette ouverture par
principe de précaution les autorités
prendront alors une décision en fonction
des résultats des analyses et nous
refermons sais pas je sentais avec cette
information hier les collectifs de
défense des hôpitaux 2.6 saint germain
et rambouillet ont diffusé leurs tracts
une partie de l'après midi à la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines les
organisations syndicales la cgt sud
solidaires fo cftc et cfdt ont déposé un
préavis de grève pour la journée du
vendredi 10 juin en cause à la loi
touraine et la mise en place des
groupements hospitalier de territoire et
syndicats et les collectifs estiment
qu'ils auront pour conséquence la
fermeture et l'éloignement de nombreux
services
il dénonce une attaque contre l'emploi
et la pression qui pèse sur les agents
des hôpitaux publics ainsi que leurs
conditions de travail
il appelle donc à manifester le 10 juin
à versailles contre ces mesures écoutez
les c'est l'éloignement des de l'offre
de soin pour l'ensemble des malades et
et des gens en général c'est à dire que
la famille doit suivre les proches
doivent suivre également les malades et
pour le personnel c'est l'économie
d'échelle c'est que de toute façon on
envisage d'ores et déjà de supprimer du
personnel dans les hôpitaux publics
nous réclamons et nous ne demandons pas
la lune d'avoir un hôpital public de
qualité avec les des prises en charge de
qualité des patients
voilà donc ce que nous réclamons c'est
l'arrêt de la mise en place des
groupements hospitalier territoire et
l'arrêt des politiques d'austérité aux
hôpitaux pour que ce 6 et les moyens de
leur mission un sujet dont nous
reparlerons demain en plateau avec nos
invités des représentants syndicaux
santé du département
passons aux sports à présent l'euro 2016
se jouera dans les bars pour les
supporters il viennois qui n'ont pas eu
la chance d'avoir des places pour
assister au match de l'euro alors dans
les yvelines une cinquantaine de bars
proposeront des rendez vous quotidiens
pour regarder l'intégralité de la
compétition
zoom sur deux d'entre eux avec michael
almy 0,2 million de billets ont trouvé
preneur pour les 51 matches de l'euro
2016 pour ceux qui n'ont pas réussi à
obtenir le précieux sésame il reste les
écrans géants ou les bars dans les
yvelines une cinquantaine
d'établissements proposent des rendez
vous quotidiens pour ne rien manquer de
la compétition on peut accueillir
jusqu'à 200 personnes
sans aucun problème on a 8 et les fixe
un grand écran on a un deuxième est
qu'on peut installer à l'extérieur qui
permet de couper aussi des espaces
l'extérieur lelangue en terrasse donc
oui on a même d'autres qu'on pourrait en
rajouter si ça se justifie
on attend du monde bien évidemment on
sait que beaucoup vont privilégier les
départs sous les grands centres mais
bien sûr on attend du monde on fera le
nécessaire pour que ça puisse être
remplies à chaque match pour de nombreux
établissements yvelinois les grandes
compétitions de football font recette
une rencontre de l'équipe de france pour
apporter jusqu'à 50% de plus qu'une
soirée de football classique les
structures n'hésitent pas à investir
pour l'événement beaucoup de monde cette
année un événement sportif et puis en
général sur l'agréable de se réunir
autour d'un verre voilà on établissement
plutôt conviviale et puis c'est vrai que
les précédentes éditions
les patrons sont plus rugby mais les
événements comme la coupe du monde où
l'euro ça ramène sera mais toujours du
monde
les amoureux des sports aucune femme
zone est pour le moment programmé dans
les yvelines des écrans géants
pourraient être déployés dans le
département si la france réalise un bon
parcours dans ce championnat d'or et
l'euro commence dans deux jours pour les
impatients n'oubliez pas ce soir une
émission spéciale euro 2016 sur notre
chaîne à 20 heures animé par mickaël hay
et demi d'euros et wilfrid richissime et
par allons nous transporte à présent la
sncf inaugure un nouveau dispositif un
peu particulier grâce à lui le
souterrain de la gare de trappes est
désormais propre des murs on dessine
anti incivilités ont été placés dans les
coins de ce souterrain l'objectif
dissuader les usagers d'uriner dans les
angles alors grâce à la mise en place de
ces plaques de projection to liquid
projetées sur le mur retourne donc
immédiatement sur son propriétaire et la
boucle est bouclée
le dispositif devrait s'étendre à la
gare de la verrière prochainement nous
sommes allés demander aux voyageurs de
cette gare ce qu'il pensait de ce
nouveau dispositif
écoutez la réponse il faudrait
généraliser je pense parce que vraiment
dans les souterrains et tout ça au
niveau des trains ou métro ça sent
énormément est vraiment énormément de
mauvaises odeurs je passe ici tous les
jours j'ai pas spécialement fait gaffe
mais je trouve que c'est une bonne idée
après au niveau de l'odeur je pourrais
pas vous dire j'ai pas fait gaffe mais
je pense que c'est de l'argent des quais
dépensés pour rien parce que les chats
sont toujours l'uriné je pars remarqué
de changement 8 on a une plus envie de
passer par là et là il ya déjà beaucoup
de jeunes qui passent en plein milieu
des voir ce que l'on disait que ça pue
1600 lui d'avoir 100 mais souvent ça pue
ils ont pendu thèse parlant il est temps
à présent de passer à notre chronique
comme chaque mercredi mélanie peau qui
nous a rejoint sur ce plateau on soir
mélanie on sent floral alors ce soir
vous allez nous parler d'un rendez vous
qui aura lieu sur saint quentin en
yvelines le dimanche le dimanche 12 juin
et où il sera question de convivialité
des changes mais aussi de transition ça
se passera exactement dans la maison des
bonheurs dans le hameau le village de
magny les hameaux
c'est une première une volonté voulue
par sky en transition l'association
fondée en 2010
sur l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est cette association qui
organise chaque année des plantations
d'arbres fruitiers
elle a aussi récemment créé un verger
pédagogique sur magny les hameaux
laurence renard sa présidente nous
explique ce que les organisateurs
entendent quand il parle de transition
aujourd'hui concrètement c'est comment
chacun de nous donc ceux qui participent
à cette ville en transition agissent sur
leur mode de déplacement donc comment
réparer son vélo comment réapprendre à
faire du vélo quand on sait plus comment
faire des gestes au quotidien pour moins
consommer d'énergie dans sa maison
réapprendre à moins chauffer ou avoir
des stratagèmes pour moins éclairés mais
toujours avec un confort qui est très
important
la transition s'est englobe beaucoup de
choses l'environnement l'énergie mais
aussi la gouvernance alors parmi les
participants dimanche il y aura de
nombreux acteurs de l'agglomération de
nombreux acteurs qui vont proposer toute
la journée des ateliers pour le public
et des mini-conférences d'environ 45
minutes il y aura aussi des discussions
autour d'initiatives locales
au programme il sera question de
contraception naturelle de monnaies
locales ou encore d'arbres fruitiers
pour les initiatives locales ce sont des
acteurs de l'agglomération comme le
bonheur est dans le pré une cagnotte
solidaire qui aide à financer
l'installation d'agriculteurs locaux
nous les avions rencontrés l'an dernier
lors d'une cagnotte notamment pour aider
l'installation de robert pires un
maraîcher sur magny les hameaux ou pour
que julien perrin olympique ultor et
sonia qui fournit la map le panier des
hameaux puisse remplacer certains de ses
outils de travail
le public pourra aussi échanger avec des
dalles à l'origine d'une amap sur trappe
en 2013 mais aussi du festival
alternatiba en juin 2015 ou encore
poussive line le public est aussi
appelée à contribuer à l'organisation
écouter à nouveau
laurence renard c'est assez varié pour
tous les publics
et en fait on demande aussi aux
personnes qui viennent de participer à
cet événement on leur demande de venir
d'abord avec un objet parce qu'il ya un
mini troque donc ils viennent à qu'un
objet et en échange ils récupèrent un
autre objet quelqu'un d'autre a apporté
venez avec un objet on leur demande
aussi la porte à un gâteau pour qu'en
fait il ya toute la journée il y aura
des boissons chaudes et gâteaux à
disposition en vente au prix que chacun
estime
voilà vous voir m la première fête de la
transition c'est le dimanche 12 juin de
10 heures à 18 heures à la maison des
bonheurs de magny les hameaux
les enfants ne seront pas en reste avec
des ateliers de peinture naturelle ou un
compte environnementale en musique
le programme est à retrouver sur le site
de l'association ski en transition
est-ce qu y en transition point
wordpress.com merci à beaucoup à mélanie
que faisiez-vous à dimanche dernier ce
que vous êtes allé au grand vide
greniers de montils bretons navy dont
j'aurais pu parce que je pense que
j'aurais fait des affaires eh bien oui
c'est ce que nous allons voir on va
revenir sur ce grand vie de grenier qui
a eu lieu donc le dimanche organisée par
la ville de montigny le bretonneux alors
c'est un rendez vous incontournable pour
tous les chineurs de la région puisque
c'était la 30e édition cette année et
malgré la météo comme vous le voyez le
dise il y avait beaucoup de monde
c'était l'occasion de vendre des meubles
de l'électroménager des livres et des
dvd mais aussi de faire des bonnes
affaires comme des vêtements ou encore à
des baskets presque neuf pour une
modique somme de 5 euros
alors comme thérèse 85 ans elle est
venue brader ses affaires on écoute 2
brocanteuse de ce vide-greniers
ah bah moi ça m'intéresse j'étais dans
le commerce quand j'étais jeune et j'ai
toujours gardé le contact des gens alors
pour moi c'est un plaisir et puis j'ai
vu que ça à faire un
c'est surtout pour me débarrasser un
petit peu de tout ce que j'ai j'ai
beaucoup de choses 20 il ya des gens qui
viennent de partout
il ya beaucoup d'acheteurs qui viennent
de paris d'ailleurs c'est pas que des
gens de 78 et des gens vraiment qu'ils
viennent d'ailleurs qu'ils sont
c'est également beaucoup les brocantes
des cas une brocante acquise ici pointe
et c'est à présent la fin de cette
édition je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis tout de suite le rester avec nous
vous retrouvez sephora nani pour un
nouveau numéro de kiosques que votre
magazine culturel sur saint quentin en
yvelines suivies de l'émission spéciale
euro 2016 qui sera présentée par michael
et demi d'euros et wilfrid est riche i
quant à moi je vous retrouve demain pour
un nouveau numéro du journal je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée
vous